prendre l'alsacien aux enfants c'est la
question que nous allons nous opposer ce
soir avec notre invité robert angèle
bonjour vous êtes chargé buisson pour la
promotion du bilinguisme pour le
département du haut-rhin vous êtes aussi
élu à la communauté de communes de
sélestat en charge de ces questions
j'ai d'abord envie de vous demander de
faire un bilan peut-être de
l'enseignement bilingue qui est en
progression aujourd'hui en alsace
oui absolument mon sort le
l'enseignement bilingue est
effectivement progression ces dix
dernières années ça a été un chiffre qui
a doublé en termes d'effectifs dans nos
écoles les écoles aujourd'hui ça
représente 25% de sites scolaires qui
propose le bilinguisme avec plus de 30
mille élèves qui sont scolarisés en
bilingue
en clair ça signifie un enfant sur cinq
en élémentaire et un enfant sur quatre
en maternelle ce qui est une belle
progression ce qui est évidemment une
belle progression sur l'ensemble des
deux départements
alors on voit que certaines certaines
écoles privées vont plus loin
elles choisissent l'immersion totale en
langue germanophone on va voir sept
reportages tournés par sidi madane et
daniel gerner à ingersheim dans une
école abc m une comptine sur le temps
qui passe en un ancien dans le texte
[Musique]
une démarche hors contrat avec
l'éducation nationale l'association abcm
a mis cinq ans pour mettre en place une
véritable pédagogie en dialecte car il
ya eu des réticences ce dialecte c'est
une langue de coeur c'est une langue
qu'on parle en famille qui est vraiment
réservées au cercle au cercle intime et
donc l'objectif c'était d'en faire un
outil professionnel et c'est ça et
c'était ça en fait le défi qui était qui
était à relever et donc il a fallu se
poser la question qu'est ce qu'on va
utiliser en classe
quels sont les termes dont on a besoin
quels sont les termes techniques dont on
a besoin et où est ce qu'on va les
chercher un jour de classe en alsacien
et un autre en allemand standard
ici quand les enfin parlant français
l'enseignant fait semblant de ne pas
comprendre au début personne ne parle
l'allemand a mixé des trois niveaux
grands moyens petit du coup les grands
parle déjà l'allemand les petits pas du
tout mais ils sont entraînés par les
grands est-ce que tu parles bien
l'allemand toi oui et le français oui tu
parles mieux l'allemand ou le français
une inversion complète à l'école pour
compenser à l usage du français
majoritaires dans les familles
c'est une méthode qui peut fonctionner
mais qui aurait ses limites selon les
linguistes
l'inconvénient je dirais c'est si on est
trop stricte si on cloisonne trop les
deux langues et on ne permet pas à
l'enfant de faire ces passerelles entre
les deux voire les toits langues
on apprend toujours à partir de ce qu'on
sait déjà ce va et vient entre une
langue et l'autre permettent les deux
langues ou les toits langue de se
nourrir à ingersheim l'immersion
complète n'est pas tout à fait une
réalité car à la récré les enfants se
parle tous les tours allemand en
français en truites de toute façon oui
oui c'est pour ça le bain linguistique
français elle a de toute façon donc ils
entendent l'allemand en classe
l'alsacien en classe un peu d'alsaciens
au périscolaire aussi mais en creuse la
langue de communication pour l'instant
pour l'instant c'est toujours le
français
mais qu'at-elle quatre ans rentre à la
maison pour déjeuner elle est née aux
etats-unis elle parle anglais français
avec sa maman originaire de belgique et
alsaciens avec son papa aujourd'hui
encore elle est persuadée que je sais
c'est rigolo elle est persuadée que je
comprend pas le français
même en entendant parler parce que voilà
depuis la naissance pas passé l'alsacien
elle est incapable de me parler dans une
autre langue que la leur faire un peu
fade militant de la culture et du
dialecte alsacien à la tête d'un fonds
de soutien dédié à cette cause
il est dit il la preuve vivante que le
dialecte même à tous et à toutes les
autres langues alors opérant chaîne on
voit cette immersion totale est ce que
vous pensez que c'est le modèle vers
lequel il faut tendre
alors oui je pense que l'expérimentation
va être intéressante
aujourd'hui nous avons une vraie
problématique de transmission de la
langue maternelle et tout le monde sait
qu'en alsace la langue maternelle c'est
l'alsacien c'est le dialecte au sein de
l'éducation nationale le bilinguisme qui
est proposé ne comporte pas encore
d'alsaciens nous allons y travailler ces
prochaines semaines
on aura une opportunité peut-être de
l'amener dans dans l'est dans les
prochaines années scolaires mais en tous
les cas aujourd'hui ce qui est important
c'est que on
arrive quelque part dans une certaine
structure a proposé la langue régionale
et l'immersion totale est une solution
je pense qui va apporter du plus mais
est-ce que c'est efficace puisque on
voit dans le reportage les enfants
d'entre eux parlent français continue à
parler français
alors efficace on va le on va le
découvrir c'est une première c'est une
expérimentation sur trois sites que
propose abc m
dans d'autres régions de france c'est
déjà pratiqué j'allais dire dans
d'autres pays aussi quand on veut sauver
une langue il faut bien un moment donné
aller jusqu'au bout de ses convictions
et je pense qu'à bcm a joué un rôle
important aussi d'expérimentation est le
suivant un grand intérêt l'évolution de
ces sites à immersion totale en tout cas
on voit il faut une implication des
parents pratiquer la langue en dehors de
l'école aussi absolument les parents
doivent être de vrai partenaire dans le
processus éducatif et il est très
important que ces parents fassent la
continuité après l'école après leur
périscolaire etc
mais je n'ai aucun doute là dessus
puisque les parents qui choisissent
l'immersion sont déjà convaincu du
bienfait de cette cet apprentissage et
joueront probablement le jeu entre
guillemets jusqu'au bout et permettre
aux enfants d'être aussi imprégné de la
langue régionale
en dehors du cursus scolaire d'accord
mais écoutez merci beaucoup monsieur
ange à l'expérimentation donc à suivre
est proposée sur trois sites à mulhouse
ingersheim et haguenau merci beaucoup
merci à vous